drives on smart strip by smart picked up
by tice
mark is smart with the steal
smart throws it in the tice throws it
down and the game is tied with two
minutes remaining the play by marcus
smart
the strip of siacom on the drive attempt
that's clean
and then offensively throws it over the
top to the biggest stronger tice
ability to finish if you're the toronto
raptors
celtic shooting free throw lowry to
inbound he could still catch his shoot
ciaco for the win oh almost banked it in
and we're going overtime
[Music]
this play is designed trying to get
ciaco a look
good job by jalen brown jaylen brown
pursuing and putting himself in position
to make it tough
for ciaco i'm glad we're in overtime
mike i wouldn't i wouldn't have enjoyed
the way this great game ended
the tatum was fouled before a shot
attempt so they inbound
jalen brown crossover drives gets inside
banks home the layup
forceful move to the goal
lowry backing backing falling away gets
in the paint and drills it 29 for kyle
lowry
four for 17 for the game kemba walker to
the basket finds tyson tys banks at home
beautiful feed from kemba walker walker
with four to shoot
walker crossover drives just gets it off
in time
got it kemba walker with just his second
field goal of the night
and the celtics lead by three fred van
fleet with tice chasing him van fleet
drives baseline
kicks it out to foul corner three ties
the game
norman powell makes it 104-104
tatum denying lowry powell against
walker five seconds to go powell
pulls up three-pointer won't go rebound
smart
double overtime attack him
putting pressure on the referees to make
a call and putting pressure
on this celtic defense
not a bad look but i agree with you mark
so five more minutes up on the clock
two players 45 plus ball poked away
jalen brown throws it ahead to tatum
tatum goes up and throws it down
and boston draws first blood in the
second overtime
one-on-one challenge take the challenge
active hands
comes up with the strip throw ahead and
tatum does the rest he's played 47
minutes
finds tatum tatum on the drive throws it
up and tice throws it down
jason tatum with a beautiful pass his
ninth assist to career high alan brown a
crossover drive stripped and stolen by
van fleet
[Music]
for such incredible defense individual
and team wise here tonight
lowry drives and banks at home with the
off hand there's that switch we talked
about
another perfect pass from marcus smart
bart's second triple double of his
career
20 points 10 assists 11 rebounds celtics
by two
ciaco jumper got it
drives on ciacom kicks it out up top
walker
fakes corner smart for three
bang marcus smart from downtown and the
celtics take a three-point lead
sixth three-pointer of the game and
inoby
chase off the three-point line spins
back up top to powell
puts it in powell from downtown and
we're tied again
now it's kimba walker's turn walker
drives
throws it up tice throws it down
daniel tice once again with the lob
finish
lowry and inoby straight
[Applause]
raptors now take a one-point lead marcus
smart to tatum
tatum off the mound stripped by powell
powell with one man to beat
drives into smart count it and the foul
norman powell banks it hold and a chance
for a three-point play
given up on the play look at the extra
effort it's pow
extra effort getting back into the
pitcher
still plenty of time remaining
tatum against lowry drives sidestep
flips it up
shots good two-point game and they don't
have to foul
got an evita selfie you gotta tell him
there's no help sending him to his right
center middle and get help
lowry falling away got it kyle lowry
drills the jumper and it's back to a
four-point lead
the clear side basically we're gonna
play one-on-one
allow me to have this dance mr walker
knock down fade away jumper
swim that's a bad boy mama
there goes that man
contested perfectly
and you're right mike this is great
defense this is outstanding defense by
kimball walker without fallon
but better offense by kyle lowery kyle
lowry keeps taking punches and keeps
punching back
same five remain on the court for both
teams
kemba walker throws it back up top tatum
a three-pointer bang jason chanda makes
it a one-point game
good execution though not rushing but
making sure they got a good look and
that's exactly what they got tatum
knocks down the long ball
does not have a timeout
here's smart the three doesn't go
batted out of bounds point five to go
[Music]
just scary seeing anybody get that shot
off